148.000 Euro hat mich diese winzige 23
Quadratmeter Wohnung in Köln gekostet
und damit herzlich willkommen zum
Wohnungsprojekt in dem Projekt in dem
ich eine Wohnung kaufen alles rausreiße
wir renoviere und nach meinen und euren
Träumen umbauen die Einbaulösung ist
fertig montiert das heißt dass wir uns
endlich um die Einrichtung kümmern
können bevor wir jetzt aber mit der
wirklichen Einrichtung beginnen erstmal
zu den Kosten also wirklich zu allen
Kosten ich bitte euch pausiert das Video
hier und schätzt mal in den Kommentaren
wie viel ich insgesamt ausgegeben habe
also Kaufpreis Renovierung Werkzeug
alles mit drin
an sich hat 148 000 € bekommen aber
keine Sorge Freunde da geht der Spaß es
zu richtig los
5283 € gegen an den Makler der 3,57 %
des Kaufpreises für die Vermittlung
bekommen hat 1330 € und 84 € pro Tag
kosten und 10.215 € und 56 Cent an Vater
Start Grunderwerbsteuer
Grundbucheintrag und so weiter ganz viel
Kram nach real,- Profile dann noch
Profile weil ich ja falsche gekauft habe
und die auch montiert habe und weiterer
Kram 1078 Euro und 57 Cent auch in
Baumärkten aber für Werkzeug 631 Euro
und 74 Cent auch wenn ich das jetzt
natürlich weiter benutzen kann waren das
Kosten für die Wohnung Entsorgung von
allem was ich hier so rausgerissen habe
alles was angefallen ist ziemlich glatt
170 Euro Einrichtung also Ikea von
Löffel bis Teppich Sofa und so weiter
1580 € und 54 Cent wieder Ikea aber
Küchengeräte 517 € und 24 sind Technik
die noch verbaut werden muss oder schon
verbaut ist Nuki 410 € und die Tür
automatisch aufzuschließen Beamer für
990 € und ein symphonist Ikea
Lautsprecher für 100 € ohne Handwerker
also 170.000 3005 € und 45 Cent das tut
weh der größte kostenpunkt waren aber
keine Sachen die ich gekauft habe
sondern Leistung die ich mir eingekauft
habe also Sachen die einfach von Profis
gemacht werden mussten Sanitär alle
Rohre neuer Durchlauferhitzer der Boden
musste nivelliert werden der war nicht
gerade an der Seite ging ja hoch also
der musste glatt gemacht werden dann
neuer Boden verlegt alle Kabel mussten
neu verlegt werden also dieser ganze
Elektriker Kram der dann in einem neuen
Schaltschrank gebündelt Einbaulösung
planen bauen und einbauen dazu neue
Fensterbänke vom Schreiner alle Wände
wurden trotz meiner sehr professionellen
Vorarbeit gespachtelt geschliffen
tapeziert und natürlich gemalt das
gesamte Bad nicht gefliest sondern ihr
werdet noch sehen das ist mein absolutes
Highlight aus der Wohnung nächste Woche
kommt endlich das Bad Video in dem ihr
das alles sehen könnt dazu natürlich die
gesamte Keramik also WC Waschbecken
Armaturen und so weiter insgesamt hat
mich die Arbeit die ich mir extern
eingekauft habe manchmal inklusive
Material 28.000 6005 € und 45 Cent
gekostet was nun mal der größte
kostenpunkt ist in dieser gesamten
Renovierung gleichermaßen aber auch
völlig gerechtfertigt ich bin mega happy
mit der gesamten Arbeit die alle Gewerke
abgeliefert haben aber der Kostenpunkt
war schon habe ich als ich das alles mal
zusammengezogen insgesamt macht das
allerdings einen Preis für Wohnungskauf
inklusive Renovierung und so weiter bis
quasi voll möbliert einzugsbereit von
1008.910 Euro und 90 Cent was ich
richtig krass finde ziemlich genau
200.000 Euro für eine 23 Quadratmeter
Wohnung und gerade deshalb bin ich
wahnsinnig dankbar dass Sponsoren wie
das mehrfach ausgezeichnete Open World
Game Genthin schon impact solche
Projekte möglich machen tauche ein in
die Welt von Tablet in der 7
einzigartige Region in verschiedensten
Stilen auf dich warten kletter schwimmen
oder fliegt durch die riesige Welt und
stelle dich mit Hilfe von Elementen
großen Aufgaben
verbessere deine Skills und deinen
character und zocken bis zu drei
Freunden Crossplay über Playstation
deinen PC oder sogar mobile komplett
kostenlos ja richtig gehört Genthin
schon iMPACT ist komplett free to play
mit dem hier eingeblendeten Code
erhältst du sogar noch einen ingame
Bonus der den dabei hilft dich durch die
fesselnde Story zu kämpfen zu zaubern
und zu leveln das Game wird
kontinuierlich weitergeupdatet und
verspricht diesen Spielspaß in einer
unglaublich schönen Welt mit immer neuen
Story Quests Gegnern und Items
über den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung oder diesen QR-Code
kommt ihr direkt zum Game ladet euch das
Spiel runter fangt an zu zocken und
vielen Dank an Gänschen impact fürs
möglich machen so eines Projekts euch
jetzt viel Spaß weiter beim Video
wir sind bei unseren schwedischen
Freunden im Einrichtungshaus um eine
1.000 300 € Bestellung abzuholen alles
dabei was wir brauchen also wirklich von
hosenöffner über Bettbezüge 52 Artikel
1300 € und klicken collect hat wieder
mein Arsch gerettet klickst das einfach
alles auf der IKEA Website zusammen und
am nächsten Tag holst es einfach hier ab
muss nicht hier durchlaufen das ist ein
absoluter Traum nächster mit dem Benz
von meinem Bruder gekommen
halber Camper werden
übrigens wieder Arbeitsschuhe an
[Musik]
wie ein Zug und irgendwie so real,-
nachträglich eingebaut Hochschrank quasi
bis hier geht innen drin der begehbare
Kleiderschrank der Apotheker
klamottenschrank und hier noch zwei
Bretter hingehangen damit man da schöne
Sachen abstellen kann und das beste ist
wir haben hier drin ja noch Platz diesen
Platz haben wir genutzt so dass der
Hochschrank nicht quasi soweit in den
Raum hängt sondern eher nach hinten
wärmer komplette tiefer für Teller und
alles weitere was wir so brauchen
richtig geil ich gebe euch jetzt einen
Tipp das hier ist das number one
Geschenk für jeden der auszieht und das
ist ein Geschenk fürs Leben Proxxon
Ratschenkasten in Groß wirklich Retter
in der Not habe ich Max zu Weihnachten
geschenkt und eine große Ratsche für
kleine Ratsche sehen von zehn
[Musik]
ich habe heute einen Kamera Praktikanten
dabei vielleicht merkt man
das ist unglaublich jetzt tatsächlich
die Bude zusammenzubauen ich mache das
ganze hier nicht für mich natürlich auch
für mich aber auch für euch die Bude
wird wenn alles so klappt wie ich mir
das vorstelle die ersten paar Monate
sind vermietet wenn er also schon immer
mal nach Köln kommen wolltet dann könnt
ihr das tun und hier in der Bude bleiben
und genau dafür habe ich die bestens
ausgestattet
ich habe nur das Beste Zeug für euch
gekauft und hoffentlich an alles gedacht
also von Weinöffner über Töpfe Teller
und diesen ganzen Scheiß ist alles dabei
damit ihr nicht probieren müsst ihr in
der Bude mit irgendeinem Schuh und
Klopftechnik Weinflaschen zu öffnen weil
es gibt nichts was mehr attackt als in
Erwin zu kommen und dann irgendwelche
Sachen nicht parat zu haben nur das
Beste eben für euch
einfach hammergeil was Firma Marenbach
hier abgeliefert hat ist einfach alles
so offen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier eine gesamte
Küchenausstattung gekauft ich glaube
aber dass der Großteil der Leute die im
Airbnb vorbei schauen ähnlich hier drin
kochen werden Ehrenfeld also wir sind in
Ehrenfeld so viel kann ich schon mal
sagen die gibt's einfach viele gute
Möglichkeiten zu essen geil hammer geil
Alter und ich merke wir haben extrem
viel Stauraum also das ist genau das
wollte ich auch haben damit wir
langfristig wenn nachdem die Zeit das
vermietet wird die Leute wirklich wohnen
können also auch Winterjacken und so
weiter verstanden jetzt haben wir aber
so viel Stauraum dass ich gar nicht weiß
wohin damit unter der Spüle das kann ich
behindert diesen komplett krank hier
also dann der Schrank des Jahres der
Apothekerschrank
[Musik]
was die Leute hier rein tun sollen also
viel zu viel Platz und hoffentlich
erfreut sich eine Person wie die
langfristig nie dass sie alles hier
unter bekommt aber es gibt ja auch noch
im kellerabteilung hier kommt jetzt die
Sitzmöglichkeit hin und darum kümmern
wir uns jetzt es ist extra kein Sofa
geworden damit ihr nicht mehr als zwei
Leute während die Zeit kennen können und
dass man nicht dann zu viert diese Bude
hier quasi doppelt so schnell durch und
äh wie es eigentlich gedacht ist für
zwei Personen also hier jetzt Teppich
Beistelltisch und setzen
[Musik]
es ist genug Platz es ist sogar genug
Platz würde ich sagen dass man da vorne
einen Esstisch hin macht was hältst Du
davon dass wir hier einen Club Esstisch
hinmachen
[Musik]
heute der finale Touch das Bett wird
bezogen es werden Bilder an die Wand
gehängt der Tisch kommt rein die Stühle
kommen rein und damit sollte die Wohnung
dann fertig eingerichtet sein
[Musik]
wir haben wunderschöne Bilder ähm Bilder
die quasi im thermikrahmen entstanden
sind von meinem Bruder das ein Laurenz
allerdings in der Videobeschreibung die
Waren in den Alpen und dabei sind
folgende Bilder entstanden und die
kommen in den Flur quasi für eine kleine
Galerie im Flur haben und dann haben wir
eigene Bilder von uns in der Wohnung
hängen die ziemlich cool sind
[Musik]
Bilder hängen und sehen richtig gut aus
also vielen Dank noch mal an Laurenz und
alle Beteiligten das ist wirklich
richtig geil Ikea Rahmen kleines Geld
wie sagt man große Wirkung also jetzt
gilt es den Klapptisch anzuhängen über
der Heizung hätte ich ihn eigentlich am
liebsten gehabt dann werden wir direkt
vom Fenster gewesen passt aber alles
nicht auf diese Wand wird das immer Bild
Gebiet und quasi da drunter kommt jetzt
der Klapptisch wenn man ihn nicht
braucht klappt man den zusammen tut die
Stühle in den Einbauschrank und hat
quasi komplett Platz kann sich bewegen
die Bohrmaschine kann nix alter das ist
so ein kleines Drecksding
Digger die kann gar nichts Müll Alter
kurzerhand neue Maschine gekauft Bosch
heavy duty ich bin sehr gespannt ob das
jetzt funktioniert
ein bisschen gekommen bin
ja ich bin da so rein oder so nach links
oben nochmal gerade nach vorne
es ist so einfach so jetzt der Chef
traumhaft
so ein bisschen ackern sehr gut gehen
dann sage ich meinen Klapptisch
Klappstuhl wieder sehr einfach in den
dafür vorgesehenen Einbauschrank noch
hinzu und mein gesamtes Esszimmer
verschwindet an der Wand und im
Kleiderschrank
es wird nicht nur eingerichtet sondern
ihr seht schon patrick ist wieder da
immer großbach alles was gemalt werden
muss im Raum Köln der beste
Ansprechpartner die Fenster werden
gemacht das sind Holzfenster nicht genau
auf den Ton den wir beispielsweise eine
Arbeitsplatte oder am Boden haben
deswegen haben wir uns dafür entschieden
das weiß zu machen einfach möglichst
hell möglichst weiß und nach außen
dürfen natürlich nichts verändern das
Bild vom Haus muss immer gleich bleiben
nach hinten weiß ich nicht ob wir dürfen
ja zum Glück ganz
aussehen kann
[Musik]
ein absolutes drunter und drüber in
dieser gesamten Zeit zwischendrin war
ich in Panama habe für euch das während
des sins produziert ich hoffe in den
nächsten Projekten das ein bisschen
zusammenhängender zu machen aber es war
dieses Mal einfach nicht anders möglich
nichtsdestotrotz nächste Woche kommt das
badezimmer-video mein absolutes
Highlight das Bad ist wirklich was ganz
besonderes geworden so viel sei schon
mal gesagt wir haben es nicht gefliest
sondern ich habe eine Firma beauftragt
die die Wände ganz speziell beschichtet
17 Tage Arbeit haben die da reingesteckt
es ist unglaublich geworden wenn ihr das
nicht verpassen wollt vergesst nicht den
Kanal zu abonnieren das Video zu liken
wenn es euch gefallen hat macht's gut
bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]